So, welcome everybody. Uh, today uh,
we're going to talk uh, in lecture six
about uh, generative models uh, for
robotics.
And uh, I'm very excited to talk about
this um, very important topic for robot
learning today.
Um, let's start with a quick recap of
why we care about generative models in
the first place.
Um, so the fundamental question or
sorry, the fundamental issue in robotics
uh, as we talked in the third lecture
um, is that uh, the mapping from
observations to actions is not a
function. It's like really a
distribution. And there are like
>> [clears throat]
>> two uh, main reasons we uh, uh, covered
why this is uh, to kind of motivate why
this is, right? Uh, the first one is
like the stochasticity, right? So, uh,
for example, with the like this 7° of
freedom arm,
uh, we already mentioned that there are
like infinite ways how we could uh, kind
of reach the same uh, goal state. And
the second one is uh, like the
inconsistency of experts, for example,
when they collect uh, demonstration
where there might be um, you know, like
uh, many different modes uh, how they
collect um, demonstrations for the same
task, right? Maybe one day they they
they like operate the robot faster or
they have like a different mood or one
day they do a side grasp, the other day
is like a top-down grasp. So, there are
many ways how to like uh, achieve the
uh, the same task and goal, right? And
this essentially means that um, our
policy for our policy, we would like to
learn a distribution over actions.
Um, and uh, the um, the the generative
modeling part comes uh, handy uh, to
help us solve this uh, modeling of the
distributions.
Um, if you remember, like we already
covered that when you train like a
deterministic policy with behavior
cloning um, that um, you know, with uh,
the mean squared error, like the math
will kind of force us to look for the
average um, of um, all the
demonstrations, right? So, you might end
up in the
hitting the tree in the middle of the
obstacle instead of going left or right.
>> [clears throat]
>> Um and so
Um we So, we kind of agree we need to
learn like if the full distribution,
right? And the question is how do we
actually represent this high-dimensional
uh multimodal distribution, right?
And so, we today we will cover like kind
of three
like three families of generative models
that uh try to answer this question from
different angles. Uh starting with the
autoencoders that learn like a compact
latent representation. Then diffusion
models uh that rather than um encoding
structure explicitly learn to
iteratively denoise uh to clean samples
and then we'll finish with flow models
uh that learn a deterministic um
invertible transformation that maps a
sample distribution to a complex data
distribution.
>> [clears throat]
>> And we will also kind of cover how all
these three
are behind many of the advances in robot
learning in the
last couple of years.
So, before we dive into the specific
architectures, um kind of to
um to uh make sure that we all share the
same model of what we uh
uh what we mean when we say like
generative modeling is
kind of the same underlying concept no
matter like if it's a VAE or or a
diffusion or flow or GANs or anything is
that um
uh generative model is a uh learned
transformation uh from a simple
tractable distribution into a complex
data distribution uh P data. Um so,
typically uh we will start with
something easy like a standard Gaussian
uh from noise uh and then we will want
to map this into the target data
distribution that we actually uh care
about or model.
>> [clears throat]
>> So, it could be like images of cats uh
like you see in the slide or
uh
for us um robotics this could be like
robot action trajectories.
Um so one way to handle this multi
modality question we a little bit
already like pre-faced in in the
imitation learning lecture
with the latent variable models, right?
Which allows us to really index into
different modes of the distribution like
go left or go right via this latent Z
where we can now say how to condition
our policy on like going left or right.
Um
but we didn't really talk about much
about how we can actually train
to compress how we can learn to compress
the
experts action into this latent Z. So we
can learn this mapping.
And this is where the architecture of
the auto encoder comes in and the idea
behind is like pretty simple. You've
probably seen this before.
We have two networks an encoder F I
that compresses the input X into a
compact latent representation Z
and then a decoder
G theta
that
takes the latent code and then tries to
reconstruct the original
input back with for example L2 norm
loss.
And that's it like we don't need any
additional labels or anything so it's
pretty like self supervised.
And [clears throat]
the bottleneck here in the middle
essentially forces the encoder to learn
like this compressed
of the data because the only way to
achieve like a low reconstruction error
is to preserve like the most important
like features let's say, right?
Of the data distribution.
So
this naive auto encoder can compress
data that's true but it has
some limitations.
First of all the latent space has no
structure so the encoder can place
clusters anywhere it wants.
There's nothing like forcing it to like
enforce any structure in the in the loss
or so.
And the second one is the only
regularizer is the size of the
bottleneck itself, right?
Um
So, the dimension dimensionality of the
of the Z bottleneck is what constrains
how much information can pass through.
Um but [clears throat] it doesn't say
anything about how like this information
information should be organized, right?
Um and then third and kind of the
probably like for us the biggest
crucial limitation is that this is a
deterministic model, right?
So, each input maps to a single point.
And so, there is really like no
distribution really. And
so, this means that we also can't like
sample new data at test time if uh
if it's a deterministic.
And so, here is where the variational
autoencoders
kind of like come in to
solve all three problems that we just
mentioned.
The key idea is that instead of encoding
to a single point,
we encode it to a distribution over Z.
So, specifically the encoder in in like
most popular case will um
output the parameters of a Gaussian like
a mean and a variance sigma. And then we
sample Z from that
Gaussian before passing it to the
decoder.
Um and then um
kind of to enforce the the structure of
the on in the space, we add a
regularization term
that forces this approximate posterior
to stay close to
our Gaussian prior.
Um and so, mathematically
our goal here is to maximize the log log
likelihood of the data. Um so, log P of
theta X. Um however, it's often um, as
we discussed also in the third lecture,
uh intractable to compute this directly.
Uh, so in instead we maximize um, the
evidence lower bound uh or the elbow.
>> [snorts]
>> Um,
and so the reconstruction loss here is
um,
uh similar to um, to the knife out and
quarter, just that now we have an
expectation uh a set is not
deterministic anymore, right? So now we
are asking on average over all the sets
I might sample given this X, um,
how well [clears throat] does the
decoder recover uh the original X.
Uh, and then the the KL regularizer is
uh what um, kind of like penalizes it
from deviating too much from uh
distribution.
Maybe the the key message here is that
um, or the key advantage is that now um,
in principle at test time we can sample
any Z uh from our uh P of uh Z and then
decode it into a meaningful output. So
now we really have a generative model.
Um, but there is one problem that we
have faced in the previous lecture, too,
um, that this stochastic uh sampling
step is not uh differential. Um, I
didn't get to the chance to really talk
about this um,
uh during the policy gradient uh
derivation,
um, but here last week, but here it kind
of appears again. Um, um,
>> [clears throat]
>> so uh what we can do here is that
instead of sampling uh Z directly from
um, the distribution that the encoder
predicts, we can uh rewrite it as a
function as a deterministic function of
um, the parameters um, and the and an
external source of uh noise.
Uh, and so we uh pull a random vector
epsilon uh from a standard uh normal
distribution,
um, and like this has like no learnable
parameters. Uh, and then we define uh Z
um, equals uh the mean uh plus uh sigma
and then like the element-wise
product with epsilon.
And you can see
on the bottom like how now the
computation graph pulls this kind of
this randomness
to the side.
And so now now for the perspective from
the perspective of the gradient
now
our mean and variances are just notes in
a standard deterministic
calculation and the gradient can flow.
Okay, so we have seen like the nice
graph on one formula, but why does this
make sampling the sampling operation
differentiable?
And so there are core problem is that
the computing the gradient of the loss
with respect to the encoders parameters
phi
is difficult because the loss involves
an expectation
under a distribution that itself depends
on phi.
And so there are like two ways how you
can handle this. The first one is what
we saw last week, which is
the score function estimator,
which in RL we call we call reinforce.
And here like you can use the same
derivation we did last week with the log
derivative trick
to move the gradient inside.
Um
but one thing to notice here is that in
this formulation the gradient only acts
on the log of the Q term ignoring
completely how the Z itself
changes with phi. So this means that
this will have very very high variance
because the the gradient has no way to
see into the function of Z itself. So
basically the optima
will be kind of guessing
because it knows if a sample was good or
bad, but it doesn't know
how to shift the mu and sigma
to make it better.
And the second option is the
re-parameterization re-parameterization
trick
that uh
we just covered
where by rewriting and substituting Z
with the formula from the previous
slide, we can see that P of epsilon is
now completely independent of phi.
So, we can move freely the gradient
inside the integral again
similar to last week cuz it's a linear
operation.
And using a Leibniz rule
>> [cough]
>> and once [clears throat] it's inside, we
can convert this back into a expectation
over epsilon.
So, which in practice means that we can
now sample
one epsilon compute the gradient and
that's it. We're done.
Um
Yeah.
Okay. And
um
Yeah, so
Mhm.
Exactly. So, the key thing here
kind of to remember is that now
with this,
we can kind of the gradient of the loss
with respect to phi now equals to the
gradient of
F with respect to Z. So, this means that
this is coming from the decoder and it
tells us
which direction like we should like move
or update our Z.
Um
So, it kind of directly tells us like
how our encode encoder parameters will
influence our latent.
Cool. So, after all this math, what does
this actually buy us?
So, if we look at this now,
the latent space and compare it to the
previous encoders,
we have now a more continuous and
structured latent space.
And it's generative because now we can
sample Z
and like the decoder will produce
meaningful outputs.
And at [clears throat] test time we
don't even need the
encoder for generation.
We can just simply
sample from Z from our Z from our prior
distribution and then use the decoder.
Um
So, although variational autoencoders
are powerful, they don't come with
without limitations.
Concretely, it has two kind of common
failure modes. First,
if you have like a powerful
high-capacity decoder,
in principle,
it could also try to learn P of X
directly.
So, this means that it could learn to
completely ignore
the
latent Z that you are passing to the
decoder.
So, in this case, your model will become
like a unconditional
Sorry, deterministic [clears throat]
model once again.
The second one is a bit more subtle.
It's what's called the prior mismatch.
So, imagine [clears throat] we have
trained our model on these two
modes of going either left or right,
right?
And now imagine that a test site this
works beautifully. We have trained on
this and now at test time we sample a
set from our Gaussian prior that lands
in in the middle in between left and
right.
Now, the [snorts] issue is that the
decoder has never seen a latent in that
region because we had no demonstrations,
right? So, even though our math kind of
forces our
latent [clears throat] space to be
continuous,
the decoder will in that case like
hallucinate
you know something that will be
completely wrong and
this will be this is especially
big issue in robotics where you don't
want to be hallucinating like unsafe
actions for example.
One way to alleviate this issue is by
replacing the continuous Gaussian latent
set with a discrete codebook of K learn
vectors
in what are commonly known as vector
quantized VAEs.
So the intuition behind this is simple.
Imagine you have a dictionary or a
codebook of
K learn vectors.
Now when the encoder looks at an image
and produces a continuous vector,
we don't pass that continuous vector to
the decoder. Instead we perform
a nearest neighbor look up.
We find one of the vectors in our
codebook
that are closest to it and then pass
that discrete code to the decoder.
>> [snorts]
>> The encoder now essentially is forced to
commit
to one discrete code rather than
producing
a Gaussian distribution and this kind of
eliminates this posterior collapse we
just mentioned before.
And so also there is no KL divergence to
minimize and no way for the decoder to
ignore Z because
the Z is now kind of a hard discrete
selection.
Mathematically [clears throat]
we are performing a quantization
with this arc of min look up operation.
But again this is kind of a recurring
pattern like there is no this is not per
se differential operation.
So concretely this means if we nudge a
bit our latent uh let's say, like the Z
to the left or right,
um then uh in principle um the the
closest neighbor uh will be still the
same.
Uh because um argmin is a piecewise
constant function, uh so it means the uh
effectively the gradient is like zero
almost everywhere.
So,
>> [clears throat]
>> how do we fix this? Um
So, in practice, we used a
uh a straight-through uh estimator,
which uh in essence just says, "Let's
pretend the quantization step didn't
happen uh during the backward pass and
uh pass the gradients along."
Um so, the high-level intuition of this
is that if um Zq and uh Ze live in the
same embedding space,
um then by by definition, they will be
very close to each other. Uh so, the
gradient that tells the decoder how to
change uh Zq to reduce the loss is
probably a a very good proxy uh for how
the encoder should have changed
Ze, so like the the latent produced by
the encoder in the first place. So, this
means that we essentially uh copy the
gradient from the decoder's uh input
directly back into the
uh encoder's output.
Um
and um yes, and here um the SG in the
formula stands for the stop gradient, uh
>> [clears throat]
>> which acts as an identity in the forward
pass,
um uh but has uh zero gradient in the in
the backward pass.
And um yeah, and here you can see now
how that kind of like
um resolves
uh in the backward pass to copy um the
decoder's gradient directly to the
encoder.
Cool. Um so, how does the loss for
training um the VQ-VAE uh look like? Um
so, we have the standard reconstruction
loss on the left, where the encoder and
decoder are trained jointly uh via this
straight through gradient estimator.
Then the second term is the codebook
loss, which moves the codebook vectors
towards the encoder outputs to
essentially learn
a representative like kind of vocabulary
of the data distribution.
And then finally we have the commitment
loss.
So for this kind of proxy gradient that
we just talked about with the straight
through estimator,
in order to for this to stay valid, we
need to make sure that
like the Z E and Z Q, so the encoder's
latent and the quantized version
actually stay close to each other.
So without this penalty, the encoder
could output values
that are very far away from the actual
codebook vector.
All right. So this training gives us
codebook and a decoder. But the question
is like okay, like how do we actually
like sample, how do we generate like new
data at test time, right?
>> [snorts]
>> Cuz this doesn't seem
to produce it.
So
in order to do that, to generate new
data with VQ-VAEs, we have a second
training stage.
So the idea is pretty simple. So
concretely once we have trained our
VQ-VAE, we run this through our data set
and collect the sequences of code
indices that our encoder picked. So this
means we're essentially translating our
data set into a sequence of discrete
tokens. Now the second training stage
consists in training a prior model over
the sequence code.
Typically this could be let's say an
auto regressive transformer.
And so then this model will learn like
given some initial first codes, what are
the next most likely tokens or or or
codes, right?
Um
and then uh we finally get to the
inference stage, right? Uh here we will
now sample from our prior, um let's say
like our auto-regressive transformer
model,
then do a lookup um
uh from the indices to the vectors, and
then use our decoder trained in the
first stage uh to generate a clean
sample of data, like an image uh or
robot actions in our uh case.
So, to wrap up the section on
autoencoders, here is a visualization um
of how the latent space evolves across
these uh three formulations or the
variants uh we discussed um in uh
VQ-VAEs have fixed most of the issues uh
we presented, like the posterior
collapse uh or the prior mismatch. Um um
they still have some issues, like uh
codebook collapse, which means that, for
example, it can be the case that many
codes uh get um
go unused during training because the
encoder converges to just uh using only
a small subset of
uh K vectors. Um
this is why uh nowadays people use, for
example, FSQ, uh finite uh finite uh
scalar quantization as a more robust
alternative, but we won't um we don't
have time to go into the details of
that.
Um and some other limitations are like
uh you need to know in advance uh the
size of your uh
uh codebook, for example.
Um and even with discrete codes, um
mean-seeking behavior at the output
level uh remains if our reconstruction
loss still uses MSE. Uh so, you can
still get, like, blurry face images, for
example.
Um to summarize, uh VQ-VAEs uh turn
continuous signals into discrete tokens,
enabling transformers uh to reason over
observations, uh actions, and behaviors
in a unified uh token space.
In robot learning, um
you can find them, um, across, uh, many
different applications. Um, like, uh,
for example, they are very popular for,
um,
>> [clears throat]
>> tokenizing images and videos, uh, as you
can see, uh, on the on the left side.
>> [snorts]
>> Um,
>> [clears throat]
>> uh, in models such as, uh, Gaia, um, for
uh, self-driving, uh, or Cosmos, uh,
video models. Um, they're also quite
popular for latent action learning, uh,
where works like La Pa or or Genie use,
uh, VQ-VAEs to quantizing to quantize
the movement between, uh, frames of of
games or egocentric human, uh, videos
and to translate then these latent codes
into robotics.
Um, and my own work, uh, used it, uh,
to, uh, quantize latent plans from play.
Um, and finally, on the right side, um,
you can also see, uh, VQ-VAEs uh, are
also, um,
used, um, sometimes to discretize, uh,
continuous, uh, robotic actions, uh, for
VLAs and such.
All right. [clears throat]
Um,
so, we have seen that, um,
kind of like VQ-VAEs have still this
limitation,
um, of having like, uh, mean seeking
behavior in outputs,
uh, where we used the MSE loss, right?
Um, so, rather than learning a
compressed representation, um,
of the latent space and decoding from
the space,
uh, diffusion model ask, uh, what if we
learned, um, directly to model the full
continuous distribution, uh, over X
without any bottlenecks at all?
So, on a high level, um, the diffusion,
uh, has two processes, um, during the
forward pass,
we take a clean sample, um, like this
image of the cat in on the, uh, of
on your left.
Um,
>> [clears throat]
>> and then iteratively add Gaussian noise
until all information um is lost.
And then on the backward process, we
train a neural network to denoise um
that um
um static step-by-step uh to learn to
recover the clean image uh from that
noise.
Now, by framing um this problem this
way, um we aren't asking the model
um to guess like the image in one shot,
but we are asking it to to we are asking
it to make um small incremental
corrections, which is a much easier
learning problem than doing everything
in one go.
Okay. Um
we'll look a bit into the details of how
these things work now.
Um so
for the forward process, uh as I just
said, like we are iteratively adding
data. Uh if you look at the equation,
uh we look we define the next state um
as a weighted sum
uh of the current state and some um
additional noise,
random noise. Um the first
uh term is uh in the equation, the
signal decay.
Uh at every step, this means we slightly
shrink uh our current sample, pulling it
a little closer to zero.
And then the second uh term is the noise
um scale.
Uh the term uh beta beta i is what we
call um the naise the noise schedule or
the var uh variance schedule.
Uh it's a hyperparameter that determines
exactly uh how much noise noise we
inject at every uh step.
Um and notice we're using the
reparameterization structure here again,
uh writing the noisy sample as a
deterministic function of the current
state uh plus some fixed noise uh
variable. Uh we will see the benefits of
this in in couple of uh slides.
Okay, what about the reverse process? In
principle, the reverse distribution is
uh intractable, right? Because um
infinite clean images could have
produced um the noisy version. Right?
There is no way to know like which one
this is the correct one.
>> [snorts]
>> Um so, here is a key insight that makes
diffusion models actually trainable. Uh
instead of asking the network to predict
the um the previous image, so X uh
I minus one, uh directly, which is uh a
hard kind of ill-posed problem, uh we
ask it to to predict uh something much
simpler, um the noise that was added.
Um
specifically, we train a
a net uh a neural network that takes the
noisy image
and a the time step as an input, and
then predicts the uh the noise that was
uh
added at that step.
Um
>> [clears throat]
>> So, and as I said, like why is this a
better learning problem? Because um
uh noise is just a sample from a
standard Gaussian, and um so, it's like
a really like clean like uh easy
regression target. Um and because we
know exactly how much noise was added
during uh the forward process, uh we can
train this with a simple MSE uh loss
between the predicted noise and the uh
actual noise.
Uh and as I as forementioned, like each
um
individual denoising step is uh a small
kind of like local correction,
uh and much easier than having to
predict everything in one go.
Um so, let's look at a training
objective, and um you'll notice
immediately that
uh it's uh kind of the the same elbow
objective um
uh as uh in the variational autoencoder
case, uh just that we extend it now uh
across uh T uh steps.
Um so there are three terms, the prior
regularization
um it ensures that after um
T steps of uh noising um
the uh
um the end result will look like a a
Gaussian prior um and this is um kind of
um satisfied by construction during the
forward pass. So in practice we don't
need to learn it. Um then the
reconstruction term um we already had
this before how well um can we recover?
And then the the big sum in the middle
is the uh denoising matching terms. So
this asks like at each time step how
well does our learned reverse
process uh match the true uh reverse?
Um
>> [clears throat]
>> One thing to to note here is that um now
because the forward and reverse
distributions are Gaussians with the
same uh variance
their KL divergence um simplifies to the
L2 distance between their means.
And so with a bit of math um you can
derive then um what they did in this
paper, denoising diffusion probabilistic
models um
>> [clears throat]
>> to this kind of uh more uh simple uh
term that uh you can see at the bottom.
>> [snorts]
>> Um
uh essentially like they realized that
um you could throw away like complex
weighting uh coefficients from the elbow
objective and just minimize the uh mean
squared error between uh the true noise
and the predicted noise.
All right, so
now if you look at the formula to
actually compute that loss, there is
kind of like one small issue uh and that
is that um
the formula says that we will need to
teleport from our clean data uh to some
arbitrary uh sample noise state uh
without iteratively uh doing all the
previous steps.
Uh let's say like 500 steps.
Uh
which would be a then also like OT
complexity, right?
Um so here in the slide you can see the
derivation of
how we can enable efficient training.
Um we first for convenience define alpha
the signal signal retention as 1 minus
beta and then start by unrolling X1 and
X2. Um then we substitute X1 into X2. Um
and then we get this this mess of square
roots on the right side of the slide.
Now the key thing here is that
um the two noise terms both come from
independent Gaussian distributions.
And we use the key property that
the sum of two Gaussians is also
Gaussian. So the two noise terms can
collapse into a single noise sample
epsilon.
And then when you generalize this to I
steps
um the
um
the the signal coefficient becomes the
product of all
the alphas
and then this gives us the final form
that allows us
teleporting from X0 to any noisy XY in a
single step enabling fast training.
So now let's look at how we actually can
generate
So we'll do questions after
if that's okay.
Um how we actually generate samples
with this trained diffusion model. Um
and so the first one is like the DDPM
sampling procedure.
Um where we start sampling Gaussian
noise
um iterate from uh T uh down to one,
um and then at each uh sampling uh
sorry, on each denoising step, we uh
apply um this this formula that you see
uh on the slide. Um
>> [clears throat]
>> the first one is we predict the
predicted mean,
uh so we uh take uh XY,
uh subtract the predicted noise, scaled,
uh and then renormalize. And so this is
kind of the deterministic uh denoising
step, so moving towards uh where we
think uh X0 will be.
Uh and then the second step um is kind
of a little bit interesting more
interesting. This is um we add some
stochastic um um Gaussian noise. And so
like you might be wondering, okay, this
doesn't sound like right at all, right?
So we are
um
kind of like denoising, but like why are
we adding like uh noise back in?
And so this is a little bit subtle but
important because if we run this process
purely deterministically, all samples
starting from uh different XTs would
tend to collapse towards uh the same
mean. And so um the injected noise kind
of maintains the the sample diversity,
uh ensuring that we explore the full
distribution rather than always
generating
um the same average uh output.
Um so
okay, and then kind of like in practice
um so DDPM um
can take a long time to denoise like an
image. For example, it could be around
like 1,000 steps.
Uh so it's really slow and therefore
also like difficult to apply uh in
robotics where we care for example about
our real-time control.
Um
DDIM solves this uh issue by decoupling
the number of denoising iterations in
training and in inference.
Um
the key insight is that uh instead of um
kind of stepping through all the time
steps, uh we define a small subset, uh
maybe let's say just 20 steps uh instead
of 1,000, and then jump in between.
Um and then in each step um
uh we use our
uh denoising uh sorry, our trained noise
predictor
uh to do um something uh a bit more
clever. So, we use uh the inverse of our
teleportation formula from before to
estimate what the clean image would look
like um based on our current noisy
estimate uh state.
Um and then once we have that estimate
of the target, we re-noise it just
enough um to reach the next step in our
uh subset. So, for example, um
uh jumping uh from like T100 to uh to
80.
Um
>> [clears throat]
>> and the key thing here is what is
actually missing.
Uh so, in DDIM, we don't have a noise
term. Um so, unlike DDPM, which is uh
which adds this uh
noise term back at every step to keep
things stochastic, DDIM is
deterministic.
And so, this allows us now to um
uh essentially
uh at inference time um to use uh much
fewer uh denoising steps to produce a a
clean image or or a robot action.
Um one thing to notice is that
everything we've covered so far is uh
unconditional generation, right? So, we
are sampling from our P(x) uh the the
marginal distribution of our data uh
with no control whatsoever over what
comes out at the end of this generation
process.
Uh and in practice, this is usually
almost never what we want, right? So, in
image generation, we want to condition,
let's say, on a text prompt um or for
our robots, we want um them to solve
like a task.
Um
um there is a simple fix on how we can
achieve this, right? So, we can
uh just uh pass uh along like a
conditioning information C um that can
act as an additional input to the noise
predictor
and then we can keep like the entire
training procedure the same.
Um
conditioning on C so
on C sounds simple right but we can just
pass it as an extra input but there is a
subtle problem. Um the model again
similar as in
>> [clears throat]
>> the VAEs
can learn to ignore the condition
and learn to denoise unconditionally
anyway since that's often the easier
optimization path.
Um the
kind of in the literature the the first
kind of solution to this was classifier
guidance
which required training a separate
classifier
like P condition given X
at every noise level which is quite
expensive.
Um there is a
nowadays the a different trick that's
usually more popular called classifier
free guidance
um which solves this with a with a kind
of a more elegant trick. Um so during
training
it means what they do sorry what they
propose is that they
randomly drop the condition information
with some probability replacing the
condition with like let's say a null
token or something.
Um and so essentially they are forcing
the network to learn both the
conditional and unconditional generation
simultaneously. Um
and then [clears throat] at inference
they kind of blend both predictions
so you start from the unconditional
prediction
and then the guidance scale times the
difference between the conditional and
unconditional predictions.
Um and that that difference is
essentially the direction in noise space
that the condition is is pushing us
and this this this
this W is the guidance scale
which controls how hard we move in that
direction.
Um in image generation for example
increasing this guidance scale a lot
will give you like sharper more prompt
consistent images but at the cost of
less variety and and diversity.
All right, so we've talked
a lot about like kind of the math behind
um diffusion. Um
let's see how how this comes together in
in robot learning. Uh in an actual robot
system. And so the first kind of case
study that does this is diffusion policy
uh from Chengji in 2023 who by the way
will be today's guest speaker.
Um the key insight is actually rather
simple. Everything we just derived for
image generation applies directly to
action generation. So we just replace
pixels with robot actions. Instead of
denoising an image we denoise a sequence
of robot actions
AT.
Um the training objective is exactly the
same. So we use the DDPM
loss for training, DDIM for faster
inference
with less denoising steps.
And then crucially here the observations
like the current camera image or the
robot state
get injected directly into the noise
prediction network as a condition.
Um the the best part is that unlike
previous works the proposed approach
also
doesn't require any future state
prediction. So it doesn't have to like
predict like future like images or
anything. So it's quite quite more
efficient. So the policy directly
outputs the sequence of actions
conditional on the current observations.
Um
uh maybe I'll go a bit more quick over
this.
The first thing to
notice here is
that the observation
is computed only once before K denoising
steps, right? So, we don't have to
recompute this at every step. This is
quite crucial for efficiency.
And then for the noise prediction,
they use a 1D temporal unit
treating [clears throat] like action
sequence like a 1D signal over time.
And then they inject the
observation conditioning via film
conditioning.
So, feature-wise linear modulation
that learns to shift and scale the
activations of the unit based on the
observation embedding. And then they
also
presented a transformer-based version
which uses cross-attention to condition
the action denoising on the observation
tokens.
One thing to notice here is that
diffusion policies really handle
multimodality quite well.
And in general, they we've seen
tremendous progress. Um
They work really well in also in in real
robotic systems, but they have like kind
of one challenge
that they are really like specialist
models. They work very well to fit like
a single task,
but have proven to be a bit more
difficult to scale
to learn like more generalist or
multitask policies.
And especially the transformer-based
version from the original diffusion
policy
is quite brittle and like sensitive to
hyper-parameters.
Um
There are like a few kind of follow-ups
that try to address some of some of
these limitations.
For example, we will talk more about
this
later when we talk about generalist
policies, but for example, Octo
which trains a high-capacity transformer
network on 800,000 robot trajectories.
>> [clears throat]
>> And then
defines like this readout tokens
that compresses the observations and
tasks and then attaches a conditional
diffusion decoding head that attends to
this readout token that summarizes like
the previous information.
And then really can
condition both with natural language or
goal image observations, for example.
Another interesting follow-up is the IT
block policies where the key
architectural innovation is replacing
the cross attention for conditioning
with adaptive layer normalization
Ada LN zero which
is borrowed from the diffusion
transformer literature for image
generation.
So here instead of having the
observation tokens attend
to action tokens through full cross
attention,
the conditioning information is injected
directly
uh
modulating the scale and shift
parameters of the layer normalization
inside each transformer block. As you
can see on the on the right.
And this is kind of like more more more
stable for training
and like really scales and really key
much better. And as you can see it
it is also allows handling like really
long horizon dexterous
manipulation tasks such as sushi
cutting.
All right. So now we move off to the
third and final framework flow matching.
Until now we've been kind of
destroying data with complex kind of
noise schedules.
>> [clears throat]
>> Flow matching instead asks
why not just draw a straight line
between the noise and the data.
So instead of predicting the noise
vector, here we learn a velocity field
that transports samples along
along continuous paths from noise to
data.
Um
and the [clears throat] path that we
choose here
uh is uh the a straight-line
formulation.
Um so this means that at T0, um you have
pure noise
uh and then um at T1, you have a kind of
clean data. Uh and the benefit is that
we have no complex like noise schedule
uh
to tune. Um so it's just really like a
straight uh deterministic path.
Um
the [clears throat] ground-truth
velocity um is uh the point a vector
that points directly uh from um the
noise to the data.
Uh and we train to our network to
predict this velocity uh at any given
time T.
Uh so this means that at test time, we
don't uh denoise in the probabilistic
sense. Um
uh we actually are integrating. Uh so we
we start with with noise and then use um
uh an ODE solver
uh like uh for example like a Euler um
uh step to follow uh our learned
velocity
uh towards the data.
>> [clears throat]
>> And um yeah, maybe one thing to to
notice is also the relationship uh
between these. Um so for example, if you
have a linear schedule, um then flow
matching and um
uh diffusion are actually equivalent.
Um
Uh so diffusion predicts the the noise
uh and flow matching predicts the the
velocity.
Um but they are related by a a simple
reparameterization.
Um in general, flow matching straight
lines are uh much easier to learn um and
they require fewer integration steps.
Uh and as I said, they don't have like
very complex uh noise schedule uh hyper
parameters, and this is why it's kind of
like been replacing diffusion as the
go-to framework in both image generation
and robot learning.
Um
So, flow matching already gives us
straighter paths than diffusion, but
there is still kind of like one subtle
problem when you randomly pair noise
samples
with data samples, the straight lines
between them might cross each other. And
when the trajectories cross, then
the velocity field has to represent
conflicting directions
at the same point in space,
which forces the velocity Sorry, the
learned field
to curve.
Um and so, this means that this will
then like kind of slow down like
integration.
Um So, rectified flow kind of is one
solution to this uh uh problem. Um
and they show how to do this with
kind of iterative procedure where
you train a flow matching model once,
then use it to generate coupled noise
data pairs. Um
So, you sample noise, you learn
run the learned flow to get the
corresponding data point.
Now you have your pair
of like X0 and your epsilon, and
they are now kind of naturally attached
by this flow vector, right?
And now what you do is you retrain on
these coupled pairs. Um because the
pairs are now matched by the flow
itself, the trajectories kind of
untangle,
and the crossings get eliminated. And
paths become really straighter,
as you can see in this visualization
that kind of shows the path between
uh original flow matching and the
rectified flow.
All right. Uh in robotics, um
Pi Zero uh from Physical Intelligence
was the first model to as far as I know
to adopt uh flow matching. Uh
concretely, they fine-tuned a VLM to
produce uh actions via flow matching. Uh
so, this was kind of the as far as I
know the first flow matching VLA, uh
which now has become kind of like the
standard for our default for most VLAs.
Um
>> [clears throat]
>> one nice technical detail here is that
um
instead [clears throat] of sampling uh
the flow time uniformly during training,
uh they propose uh sampling um this from
a shifted beta distribution uh that
focuses on the noisier uh harder time
steps. So, where action prediction uh
should be uh more difficult and where
the model needs to predict more.
Uh we will talk more about uh VLAs and
generative policies um in lecture nine.
Um all right. So, to to conclude uh
today we have covered um three families
of generative models, uh each answering
a different question about how to
represent uh complex data distributions.
Um
so, [clears throat] we started with
latent variable models,
uh so autoencoders that gives us
compressed representations via
reconstruction. Uh we have we then saw
how to add um kind of uh more uh
probabilistic latent uh spaces via
reparameteri- zation, uh and also with
VQ-VAEs how to discretize them into a
uh learned codebook.
Then with diffusion models, uh we've
seen uh with DDPM uh how to iteratively
noise uh Gaussians uh into data. With
DDIM, um how to make this faster and
deterministic
uh by discretizing a probabilistic flow
um ODE. Uh and then with uh
classifier-free guidance, uh how to
steer generation by blending conditional
and unconditional predictions.
And then finally with flow matching,
we [clears throat] have seen how we can
learn velocity field that transport
noise
along straight paths
and rectified flow that straighten
straightens those paths further
for even fewer integrations steps.
The [snorts]
key takeaway for
for robotics is that we started with
this simple observation
that robot
like robot behavior and action
prediction
is inherently multimodal and with MSE
regression
and deterministic policies this will
fail.
And everything we've covered today from
VAEs to diffusion models to
flow matching is kind of the the
the tools we
we use
in some of our latest and greatest
robot policies.
And [snorts]
yeah, with that thank you for your
attention.
And
yeah, let's switch to the papers.
>> [applause]